hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es mal wieder ein
sehr leckeres nudelgericht denn ich
werde heute spaghetti mit grünem spargel
machen dass ich auch ein richtig
schnelles rezept wo mal zum so in etwa
15 minuten ein leckeres gericht auf dem
teller hat das heißt es kann man auch
machen wenn man nach der arbeit nach
hause kommen und keine luft zu kochen
hat aber eben doch was frisches kochen
will und schnell kommen und einfach was
gesundes essen will ich zeige euch
einfach mal kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier einen wunsch grünen
spargel den habe ich bereits gewaschen
und die enden auch schon abgebrochen als
er zuerst geschnitten aber logisch wenn
man sie einfach auftritt hat man nämlich
das holzige ende einfach weg dann
brauchen wir bisschen olivenöl ein paar
cherrytomaten salz und pfeffer ich
brauche noch etwas chili natürlich eine
knoblauchzehe und etwas parmesan und das
ganze reicht dann für ein päckchen
spaghetti also wie ein punkt
das geht jetzt auch ziemlich schnell ich
nehme zuerst meinen grünen spargel und
das tolle man muss ihnen wirklich nicht
schaden
also das ist echt toll da bleibt doch
immer schön knackig und man kann einfach
klein schneiden oder man kann den auch
zum beispiel einfach auf den grill legen
und grillen das haben wir nämlich noch
nicht gemacht und später dann mit
olivenöl beträufeln und im prinzip mache
ich das gleiche jetzt in der pfanne und
grill die praktisch ist in der pfanne an
jetzt schneide ich die mir einfach in so
etwa 34 cm große stücke so und die kopf
enden die lasse ich jetzt erstmal
draußen denn die werden schnell erreicht
und ich will dass die auch bissfest sind
da gebe ich die erst zum schluss zu
damit ihr nicht so weich werden
kann ich eh schon mal in meine pfanne
geben und die pfanne erhitzen
ja auch ziemlich schnell auf die
induktionsfeld und ihn derzeit kann ich
dann schon mal meine knoblauch sehr
klein schneiden und auch bereits
nudelwasser kocht
jetzt lassen wir es so etwa 50 zehn
minuten anbraten je nachdem ob sie weich
oder bis selbst haben wollt also ich bei
mir als selbstlos dienen - mandaten
jetzt hier schon mal die tomaten ab die
kann ich es nicht auch schon mal
vorbereiten
einfach den stiel entfernen
mit formaten
aber nicht die tomaten aufessen okay
minute klar und ich halte jetzt noch was
mir wirklich eine tomate geklaut nein
wie kann ich in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die nudeln abkochen gibt einfach
alles dazu eine dual die nudel klaren
und tomate klötze mir auch
ich habe den herd übrigens bisschen
runter geschaltet also die haben jetzt
bei mir so etwa 5 minuten braten dürfen
aber ich lass dir jetzt warten bis die
nudeln fertig sind denn dann verkleben
modeln hat und dann kann ich alles
gleich zusammenfügen und den rest gebe
ich auch erst dazu wenn die nudeln
fertig sind denn dann kann man alles
schön bissfest warte mal einfach so
etwas sieben minuten auf die nudeln
jetzt kurz vorm nudeln abgießen gebe ich
noch mal etwas olivenöl in die pfanne
rein und gibt da helfen auch die
spargelköpfe mit dazu könnte die auch
schön mit fragen
mama mal höchste stufe
jetzt gebe ich den knoblauch dazu wenn
es den ganz kurz mit estland und den
gebe ich jetzt ein buch erst mit rein da
einfach nicht verbrennt verlangen jetzt
kommen gleich die tomaten rhein sieht
auch nicht so aus also das tolle farben
hier drin
jetzt das ganze noch etwas salzen
pfeffern
und das ist anni
ja
die pfanne aus
und die spaghettis kommen
da muss ich gut aufpasst geschrieben
einmal kurz durchschwenken sanierer
willst du ein paar ohne am irakkrieg ein
paar ohne spargel audition chiliflocken
in dem ich den wieder weg die schalter
bitte schau
bei einem bock hat kann übrigens auch
ein wochenende bisserl besser zum teil
des krieges
und was wir unbedingt noch mit rein
geben sollte am besten direkt mit in die
spargel pfanne ist etwas zitronensaft
das habe ich jetzt heute leider
vergessen ich habe keine zitrone metalle
schon aufgebraucht
aber das muss unbedingt noch mit rein
denn bis macht so den geschmack erst
richtig aus aber schmeckt auch so
richtig gut
jetzt kann man schon das essen servieren
rappaz spaghettis und gemüse
doch aber ich hab halt immer noch eine
soße dabei
wenn jetzt noch ein paar sachen drüber
und mit diesen treffer noch mal drüber
geben
und jetzt aber ganz schnell blitzschnell
und gerichte gezaubert
wenn ihr zu erstes nudelwasser aufsetzt
dann habt ihr das gericht sogar
innerhalb von zehn minuten fertig und
müssten auf sockel wasser waten und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ein abbild der morath
darf das gleich mit mir zusammen essen
also er kriegt auch noch seine eigene
fraktion und ihr dürft das rezept ja
nachlesen blog.de und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal
vergeblich die erst zum schluss zu damit
ihr nicht so weich werden weil ich hart
samira weiß es eigentlich mit die
zuschauer sollten deswegen hat sie
gefragt
du bist ja tolle bücher schon wieder
papa hat
achso entschuldigung des schneidens okay
jetzt wissen die das jahr